this is a production of Cornell
University great so I'll talk today
about controlled environment agriculture
a little bit about my outline we'll talk
about control environment agriculture in
New York State's
a little bit about urban controlled
environment agriculture and some new
research that we're doing in this area
especially working with economists and
the Dyson School then I'll talk more
about kind of the the meat of what I
want to talk about today which is
lighting in controlled environments and
talking about a bunch of our research
that falls under this consortium that we
call the greenhouse lighting and systems
engineering consortium so glaze spelled
wrong we'll talk about LED efficacy and
then some actual research with plants
and then some more engineering or
computer based research so just to get
everybody on the same page
controlled environment agriculture is an
innovative method of growing plants that
creates optimized area land root zone
environments with the focus being on
production benefit so high quality
predictable crop timing and consistently
available quantity and limited
environmental impact we hear more and
more about it these days but it's been
done for decades and done for hundreds
of years of at least growing plants
under some modified environments some of
the the examples we have traditionally
greenhouses now there's some interest in
warehouses and vertical farms and
shipping container farms which I'll talk
about and often in terms of the root
zone hydroponics are used so that
irrigation water can be captured and
reused and you can you can control the
root zone but aquaponics is also one of
the techniques where fish are combined
with hydroponic production to close the
nutrient loop and at Cornell we have a
rich history of research and controlled
environments the CEA group was founded
some 30-plus years ago by Professor Liu
Albright who was in biological and
environmental engineering at Bob Lang
hands who was in horticulture and so
they set this group on this really
excellent track of combining engineering
and sensors and
the environment with plant science and
people that actually cared about plants
and could monitor how they grow and
advise on their culture and that's been
a really productive collaboration I
often forget to include acknowledgment
so I thought I better include
acknowledgments at the beginning of my
talk here is the current crop of
graduate students in the Matteson lab
many of them are in the room today so we
can ask them questions when the question
time comes and then in terms of our
academics and staff we have kind of this
engineering sub team and I'll talk a
little bit about their research which as
kale Harbach Tim Shelford and Michael
Keaton and then we have research support
specialists in Matt Mauck Adam and
Kendra Hutchins and our current funding
comes from NYSERDA NSF and the USDA and
a little bit of the context for the
controlled environment agriculture
industry in the u.s. now there's about
2,500 greenhouse vegetable operations
and we have to use the term greenhouse
fairly loosely this would be under
protection so it could be under hoop
houses or high tunnels or it could be
under you know sophisticated glass
greenhouses with hydroponics and light
if we drew if we drill down into that
twenty five hundred operations probably
80% of them are the more low-tech
operations and about twenty percent are
the higher tech operations but in terms
of production value those higher tech
larger operations make up say about 80%
of the dollar value of wholesale farm
gate production and interestingly if we
look at new york and i can't wait until
we get the new 2017 census of
Agriculture out so we have new data to
look at but if we look at the 2012
census of Agriculture and compare that
to the 2007 in 2012 actually
floriculture is a much larger industry
in greenhouses than what I call CEA or
vegetables and small fruits and
greenhouses with a wholesale value in
flora called
about 10 times that of controlled
environment agriculture the interesting
thing is looking at its growth since
2007 so since just right before the
recession flora culture is is considered
a fairly mature industry with flat or a
little bit of negative growth versus CEI
is growing by group 54% during that five
year period of time so want to show you
a several photos of what CEA looks like
in New York State to kind of frame some
of the the work that our group does this
is Finger Lakes fresh this is located
just across from nice egg on 13 this was
a greenhouse facility that was actually
designed by Lou Albright and Bob Lang
hands just over 20 years ago as a way to
test the work that they they did here on
campus at somewhat commercial scale so
this is 6,400 square feet of hydroponic
pond production when operated well it
could produce 1,200 heads of lettuce per
day and the facility was after a few
years of testing and experimenting it
was turned over to challenged industries
that operated the facility for not quite
15 years they closed down the facility a
few years ago and I had a change in
direction and we've been pleased to see
just in the past year a new business has
has come over and taken over the
facility so now called glass house farms
the largest CEA operation that we have
in New York State currently is inter
Grove which has about 70 acres of
greenhouse production of all tomatoes so
tomato on vine lots of cherry and grape
tomatoes now and some beefsteak tomatoes
if I remember right about 20 or 25 acres
of this facility actually have
supplemental lighting so that they can
produce Tomatoes year-round for local
markets
this facility produces three acres of
hydroponic lettuce this is SAF produce
maybe one of the more visually
interesting facilities that I visited in
New York because they have three acres
of LED lights lighting their greenhouse
the history of this facility it was
actually part of a cut flower Rose
facility that operated until about
twenty years ago or so when the
economics of pet flower rose production
changed and really has moved to Colombia
and Ecuador
the facility was idle or used a bit for
the intervening years and then in the
last few years has seen a resurgence in
its use and been retrofitted and now
growing about three acres of hydroponic
head lettuce
this facility is Saunders Gill farms in
accord New York in the in Dutchess
County or sorry Ulster County the
interesting thing about this operation
which now has I think 800 acres field
vegetables bedding plants or retail
stand is that it's been in continuous
operation and in the family since 1680
which they say is the second oldest
continuously operating farm in New York
after there's one farm in Long Island
that's been operating longer interesting
about this facility I visited here
several Springs to look at the the
bedding plants and hanging baskets that
they are producing and this particular
spring that I visited a couple years ago
I noticed that they were also dedicating
greenhouse space toward growing these
are tomato plants that they're going to
be growing through to fruiting to get
Tomatoes earlier than their their field
tomatoes and in these rain gutters that
are hanging up in the rafters they're
also growing strawberries also for their
their local market and they can get
strawberries about a month earlier than
they would be able to outdoors this is a
facility I visited just last week during
a snowstorm in Syracuse which is a good
time to look at lights in a greenhouse
this is Barone Gardens and sister in New
York
traditionally they
they do floriculture production about
two and a half acres where they
propagate cutting so it's geraniums and
all sorts of bedding plants they also
finished bedding plants in the
springtime and sell them wholesale as
well as they're a retail garden center
and the thing that I've struck me as
interesting visiting last week is they
have now installed a crop of hops so
they're growing hops in the offseason in
their greenhouse and actually doing an
interline trial with philips so they
have some some LED lights that are above
the crop because it is a tall crop with
with a dense canopy they're actually
looking at the potential benefits of
lighting inside of the crop and I would
say the the economics of greenhouse hops
are questionable at this point it's a
really new crop but the the angle that
this particular operation is taking is
they're actually working with partners
to build an on-farm brewery and they'll
be having tastings and selling local
beer and even if the hops itself is is
not necessarily cheaper than hops they
can buy in the market they think that
there will be benefits of having fresh
bruised and and showing people the
locally grown products
this facility is Nanticoke gardens about
an hour south of here in Endicott New
York traditionally also a flora culture
growers they've been in business for
about 45 years so largely bedding plants
and flowering potted plants and visiting
them a couple years ago I found this new
crop that they were growing which is
industrial have and so so what they're
doing is they're actually propagating so
these are mother plants of cannabis a
particular variety that's high in CBD
but low in THC so it qualifies through
the state's
industrial hemp program and they're
rooting cuttings which they sell to
field producers that are growing
industrial hemp for sea
vd extraction so he actually still sold
the facility to two brothers and they've
done a nice job of keeping the facility
going over the last six eight years or
so very good memory done nice so of the
of the facilities that I just showed you
water a few of the themes that kind of
came out of those those photos this is
where you get to respond I know the
rhetorical question there were lights in
almost every greenhouse even if they
weren't turned on yes in the back some
of them were standalone some of them
were better connected other observations
yeah lettuce and tomatoes right Mike
they're all on the ground yes yeah so
those those are all good observations a
couple and lighting was one of the
themes that I was thinking of one that I
was thinking of his growers are quite
innovative and so I've talked about this
relatively mature flora culture industry
but that means that floriculture growers
haven't stopped growing they're looking
at other crops that they're
transitioning to so like the industrial
hemp and the hops or adding crops into
their diversified farm market let me
mention a couple urban controlled
environment agriculture facilities
located in the New York City area so
this is Gotham greens in Brooklyn New
York they're kind of flagship facility
is on top of Whole Foods and you can
actually go up to an eating area on the
second floor and there's nice windows
that you can look into and see the
production that's being done they have
four facilities one in Queens two in
Brooklyn and then one that's actually in
Chicago when you walk inside of the
greenhouse as I was able to do what what
you notice is it looks very much like a
standard greenhouse inside so here we
have channel or NFPA nutrient film
technique production of head lettuce
but being on a rooftop allows them to
grow in a place where they otherwise
probably could not afford land and
allows them access to local markets at
decent scale another facility that I
visited is square roots this facility is
developed by Kimball musk who's Elon
Musk's brother and it is ten shipping
containers and these are truly vertical
in kind of a different way so they have
these vertical channels that hang down
and then they have these strips of LED
lights that light up on both sides and
light the crop in one direction and
light a cropping in the other direction
and a large focus of square roots is
training new growers and
entrepreneurship so they annually bring
in a class of 10 new grower operators
and each one is responsible for a
shipping container and does everything
from seeding and transplanting and
harvesting and packaging to actually
bringing the product to market and
developing the market for their product
so cea has seen a lot of interest in New
York City it's interesting to think
about what is its current impact and
what could be its impact of the future
in terms of its current impact I was
happy to to sit on the committee of
Wylie Goodman who was a master student
in and city and regional planning and
she has a recent publication quantifying
the impact of urban controlled
environment agriculture in New York City
and one of the things that she looked at
is commercial farms versus nonprofit
farms in controlled environments and she
was able to find examples of seven
companies that are commercial cea farms
in New York City largely producing
lettuce and leafy greens and herbs and
then some of the other crops that show
up are microgreens fish or shellfish
edible flowers one growing strawberries
and why do you think that greens and
herbs might be one of the more common
crops yeah right right high value crops
relatively low light needs they also
have very quick crop turns as well so
maybe a three to five week crop cycle so
you get several crop cycles per year so
we often like to look at the yield that
you get in pounds per square foot per
week and those would those would produce
high yield and pounds per square foot
per week I have a current project from
NSF from their from their grant program
called innovations at the Nexus of food
energy water systems and I was pleased
to to be awarded this grant to work with
a team of economists on garage garage
and here in horticulture and two
colleagues at Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute and kind of the macro
economics approach of the project so
we're looking at the scalability or how
viable is it that urban cea
can can grow up to feed those urban
areas and in the project we've chosen
five different metropolitan area so Los
Angeles Seattle Chicago Atlanta and New
York City
those were strategically chosen to
represent different growing environments
or different heating and cooling
environments and we're looking at the
water energy and carbon footprint impact
of growing strawberries lettuce and
tomatoes either in the status quo way so
like field production and shipping 3,000
miles or growing in greenhouses with
supplemental light within the city or
warehouse farms in the city or
skyscraper farms in the city and we're
about a year into this research now one
of the early products of the of the
group was working with Chuck Nicholson
and Miguel Gomez in the Dyson school to
the beginning of a life cycle assessment
and so this is an accepted book chapter
that's going to be in flu food supply
chains in cities and we looked at the
case of lettuce I'm in the chapter we
look at producing lettuce in Chicago and
New York in either greenhouses or plant
factories versus status quo in the field
so this was field production in in
Salinas California and what we looked at
were the inputs that were required in
production and then transportation to to
market to get to a wholesale market and
then we didn't further look at the the
the crop after it got delivered to a
wholesale market assuming that it would
be a similar energy and and a carbon
footprint after that point so a couple
of the metrics that we looked at were
accumulative
energy demand so what is what was the
energy demand of diesel of operating
tractors of heating and lighting
greenhouse or a plant factory and what
we find is is a field and shipping 3,000
miles did have a slightly lower energy
demand than producing crops in a
greenhouse in New York City and then a
quite a bit lower energy demand than a
plant factory in a plant factory there's
no sunlight so all of the light that we
deliver to the plant has to come from
electricity and as well
HVAC so actually air conditioning that
facility is about half the other half of
the energy use and plants transpire an
extreme amount of water that has to be
that turns into relative humidity in the
air and has to be removed through
mechanical chilling and so that that is
a large component to the energy demand
in plant factories and then what global
warming potential would do is it would
look at the forms of energy or fuel that
are that are used and assign global
global warming potential value to them
and what we find is that
a greenhouse has has ever so slightly
higher global warming potential than
field and then similarly the plant
factory has about twice the global
warming potential to produce a kilogram
of lettuce than the field or greenhouse
water consumption comes from published
values in the literature and what we
find in the literature is is about ten
times less water usage in a greenhouse
or in a plant factory versus the field
so there's kind of some environmental
pros and cons about producing in in
urban CEA what if we actually look at
the cost producing a kilogram of lettuce
and this is probably way to numbers and
we're supposed to include in a table
let's look at the bottom line first of
all so we have field greenhouse and
plant factory and the total landed cost
to the wholesale market it's about three
dollars per kilo in a field about eight
dollars in a greenhouse and seven
dollars and 82 cents in a plant factory
when I first looked at this it's like
wait a second the energy cost in a
greenhouse was substantially lower than
a Platt factory and it was energy for
operations was 46 cents versus a dollar
and 36 cents but how can it be that a
plant Factory is actually cheaper than a
greenhouse and so one of the one of the
things that you can look at is the land
and equipment cost and in this scenario
we were assuming production in one of
the five boroughs in New York City where
land is very very expensive and so
buying a one acre to install the
greenhouse ends up being very expensive
versus if we can buy point four acres
and construct the same produce the same
amount of lettuce in these vertical
layers that allowed one to save on the
land cost one of the things that we are
looking at in this work is also para
urban CEA so if we go say an hour
outside of the city what does that do to
the to the economics where land is a lot
cheaper
we have some small delivery cost but
nothing like delivering at 3,000 miles
to mark
and interestingly so-so we've seen kind
of this this growth and interest in
controlled environment agriculture I was
able to find some global values for the
hydroponics market and worldwide CEA has
grown by about ten percent a year
annually for the last five years and
projected for the next five years that
growth looks like it's starting to slow
down so about 6.8 percent compound
annual growth rate a different study
predicts that there's going to be a 17
percent annual growth for global
hydroponics equipment so growing systems
HVAC LEDs environmental control and so
on so those those are some CA operations
some of the barriers to CEA we've
convened what we call our Cornell CA
advisory group convening industry
members that are producers produce
buyers financers suppliers of equipment
and what they say the barriers to CEA
are accessing capital and that that
probably comes up as the number one
barrier so so meaning it's a very cost
intensive way to farm building a
sophisticated greenhouse lighting it's
installing hydroponic equipment
accessing markets so actually finding
produce buyers that will commit to
buying your produce so despite what
consumers say about having an interest
in locally grown food the current
markets are well served by traditional
supply chains and it's difficult to
undercut them in price I think we have
to differentiate our value find
consumers that that want a value-added
product as I've showed you they are
energy intensive
they are labor intensive often not as
mechanized as some of the field
production that takes place and it's
actually difficult finding educated
workforce that can operate these so it's
kind of a new style of farming right so
we need a grower that can understand
computer controls understand
delivering to market and handling food
safety and so those are difficult skill
sets to to find especially in an
industry that like in New York and
worldwide is growing by by 10% per year
and then poor spatial uniformity of the
growing environment and I'll address
this with a with a few of my slides at
the end so so we say we're growing in
controlled environments but the
temperature or light that plants get can
vary greatly depending on whether
they're in the middle of the greenhouse
or at the edges of the greenhouse which
can make it difficult to grow quality
uniform crop aisle so a little bit now
about our work with with LEDs and energy
and some of the Nexus for this from our
support from from NYSERDA came out of
the New York State Energy Initiative
this is where the state has declared
goals for New York State that by 2030
we're gonna decrease our greenhouse gas
emissions by 40 percent from 1990 levels
and 50 percent of electricity in New
York State is going to come from
renewable energy ironic I was just
talking with my daughter about where
she's gonna be in 2030 she'll have just
graduated from college
apparently in her in her timeline for
her life and I was like oh great and
we'll be getting 50% of our electricity
from renewable energy by that so
hopefully those will come to fruition
[Laughter]
both of them so so in terms of
agriculture well CEA in greenhouses are
not the largest agricultural commodity
in the state which is dairy and then
it's feed and forage to support dairy
we're in about the top five if you
collectively put together greenhouse
nursery and CEA and we're a very high
energy user and so how will the state
balance the growth of the greenhouse
vegetable industry if it is indeed
growing by 10 percent a year with these
increased energy demands and some some
work that NYSERDA did to put some
estimates on it was if we look at our
current acreage in greenhouses
floriculture and vegetables
that they may grow from about 700 acres
currently to about 1400 acres by 2030
which means that the electricity for
horticultural lighting is going to
increase from 770 to 840 gigawatts per
hour annually so despite this this
increase in this growth if we look at
our greenhouses using LEDs and then
we'll talk about should they be using
LEDs there was a report done by the US
Department of Energy that found as of
2017 only about 2% of horticultural
lighting of green house lighting is
using LEDs and the rest are kind of
legacy technologies of high pressure
sodium light and metal halide light and
we'll talk more about why that is in a
minute interestingly if you look at
vertical farming which in the u.s. is
quite small globally it's a 1.5 billion
dollar industry I saw some numbers in
the u.s. maybe it's six hundred eight
hundred million dollar industry 66
percent LEDs and 34 percent fluorescent
lights so the best LEDs are about twice
as efficient as fluorescent lights so to
kind of make more sense in the case
where you don't have sunlight and
interestingly there's this other large
industry which apparently is equal in
size to the u.s. greenhouse industry
bill is cannabis which is said to be a
seven billion dollar industry in the
u.s. eighty nine percent of their lights
are high-pressure sodium and metal
halides four percent are LEDs and I
don't know if this can be true but it's
predicted to grow to a thirty 1.7
billion dollar industry by 2021 there's
now only two years away we'll see but
the main point is that while we have LED
technology there's has not yet been a
lot of industry adoption in LEDs and so
this led NYSERDA to decide to make an
investment that they call greenhouse
lighting and systems engineering which
would be research outreach and
technology transfer so my group at
Cornell is the leads or co-lead with a
group at RPI
called Lisa the lighting enabled systems
and applications group so they've
traditionally done a lot of lighting
related to humans and really nice
engineering of LEDs and thermal
management and so on they have a photo
biologist now that's done some nice work
of translating on what engineering
engineers can do with with LED lights to
what plants need with LED lights and
then we have a subcontract with AJ both
at Rutgers University who works with us
on our electrical efficacy goals so I'll
describe this interdisciplinary approach
to improving LED lighting adoption
interestingly this is a project unlike
say NSF or USDA funding where we
actually get paid according to reaching
quarterly milestones which I'm hoping
doesn't make Steve rhinos nervous but it
does like some we have to deliver
achievements or deliverables to actually
get our our quarterly milestones paid so
kind of a new model for funding that way
and this is the glaze team so so Tessa
pitaka and Bob Carla check at our PI
Ajay both at Rutgers myself in terms of
the industry consortium and and
technology transfer with the industry we
have an executive director who's Erica
Matos
he has his PhD and in plant physiology
working on LED lighting of algae at the
University of Georgia and then we have a
scientific advisory board which is
cherry Kubota who was at Arizona and
their CEA group and now she's at Ohio
State forming a CA group there and Bruce
Bugbee who's at Utah State and then our
token Engineer Morgan Patterson who's at
the US Department of Energy and we have
these multifaceted objectives and I'll
try to talk about a few of them so
relating to looking at and then trying
to improve the energy efficacy of LEDs
trying to decide how to with LEDs we can
turn them on and off in milliseconds and
we can dim them and so there's more
creative things that we can do than just
whippy flipping a switch on and off once
a day
spectrum and plant sensing so with our
collaborators at RPI we're looking at
the effects of different wave bands of
light and then we'll be adopting some of
their research in the greenhouse and
then I'll talk about our work here
looking at co2 enrichment to reduce our
need for supplemental lighting and then
engineering and modeling and pilot
demonstrations so one of the things that
we did this would go back three years
now is look at the the energy efficacy
which we called a par they could see the
photosynthetically active radiation that
we get in micro moles per Joule this was
done at Rutgers University with their
hundred thousand dollar piece of
equipment called an integrating light
sphere and so we had two high pressure
sodium lights and then we had four
different commercially available LEDs
and at that time the interesting thing
to note is there were only two LEDs that
we tested that actually were more energy
efficient or had higher energy efficacy
than high pressure sodium lights one of
them dramatically so with these philips
top lights had 40% higher efficacy
however if we looked at a scenario of
lighting a one acre lettuce greenhouse
for a year
cost of the fixtures ended up being a
large sticking point so with high
pressure sodium lights 200 and 300
thousand dollars to outfit a greenhouse
eight hundred thousand dollars to outfit
a greenhouse with the most
energy-efficient LEDs they could save us
fifty thousand dollars a year on
electricity so that would give us a
simple return on payback of about 12
years which a farmer is going to want a
payback of maybe three years to make
something economically viable um we did
find that you could grow nice crops
under them there we had leafy greens
growing under ambient light versus a few
different types of LEDs versus the two
different high pressure sodium lights
and there's no letters here what we
found was there were not statistically
significant differences in biomass
for lettuce or for arugula between the
the light sources so in a greenhouse
where we have a background of sunlight
it seems to be most important is what is
the total amount of light that we
delivered to the plant and and in terms
of biomass we saw no differences between
lighting source we have since followed
that up in a little bit more detail so
we grew these crops on a larger scale so
this is the area where we grew baby leaf
greens over a 12 month period of time we
controlled lights to a to a daily light
target and what we did is we chose the
best-performing LED lights in terms of
energy efficacy and the best-performing
high pressure sodium lights and I have
some of our data I haven't gotten a
chance to process all of the data yet
this is for arugula and and blue bars
are high pressure sodium light this is
relative fresh weight and the red bars
are under LED light one of the things
that we saw this is that when we had
kind of this shoulder season where we
had say cloudy warm days and we needed
to add supplemental light to reach our
daily light target we actually saw a
higher yield under LED lights what we
think that might be is just a
temperature effect with high pressure
sodium lights we get more long way of
radiation which was undesirable during
those those warm season months during
the winter time or later fall we
actually saw higher yield under the
high-pressure sodium lights and so it
could be that that long wave radiation
is actually desirable during those
winter months one of my recent masters
students Erika Hernandez also looked at
the response of head lettuce varieties
to LEDs and high pressure sodium lights
and she got a chance a year ago to give
it to her to SUNY Cobleskill president
Marion Terenzi Oh because I must have
been out of town and Erika's great she's
been a great communicator
in this project Erica had 13 cultivars
of head lettuce we also wanted to look
at some of the cultivar responses she
grew them for three crop cycles so from
January when you would need lots of
supplemental lighting through until May
when she needed relatively less
supplemental lighting she had an F T
channel so this channel hydroponic
production she actually physically
separated them by about 12 feet so that
there was not much light pollution
between treatments and then they shared
the same nutrient reservoir and then she
repeated over these these three crop
cycles and there were light sensors to
make sure that turning the lights on and
off to make sure that the plants got the
same daily light integral which was 17
moles per meter squared per day and you
can see the spectra in this graph so if
we go from 400 up to 850 nanometers the
luma grow fixtures had 20% of their
light was from blue 80% was from red
versus high-pressure sodium light is a
much more broad spectrum light so a lot
of light in the yellow orange red region
and then that that far red or infrared
radiation and interestingly over the
course of those three growth cycles
there was only one cultivar where Erica
statistically significant difference in
on fresh weight comparing high-pressure
sodium growing planets versus LED plants
and that was Tia door a what we when we
went back and looked at our observations
of this plant what we found is that
under high pressure sodium light the
plant bolted earlier so it started going
to seed earlier than its counterpart
under LEDs and so what we do have a
higher fresh weight it's actually an
undesirable form of the plant and so
some of those temperature effects of
high-pressure sodium light come out from
that Erica also looked at differences in
plant size based on cultivar basically
found this a very broad range or we
could get some romaine lettuce --is that
were very large so 225 grams
versus some very small varieties like
karma Z which has a nice ruffled leaf
but four times the four times less
biomass and so these observations then
can be helpful to growers showing that
cultivar selection and their their
operation is very important one of the
things that Erica did a nice job of is
estimating energy usage of that
high-pressure sodium light array versus
LED array and we have to give some
caveats this was lighting a very small
research area so each one lighting about
a 12 foot by 12 foot area so there could
have been a lot of light loss to the
perimeter the high-pressure sodium
lights are kind of what we have at kpl
so they're not new high pressure sodium
lights they're old magnetic ballast
fixtures with old bulbs and so the the
data that Erica compiled based on the
lighting control we have the number of
hours that the lights were on per day
and so the first harvest so this was the
cycle that took place in January in
February the lights were on for 18 to 19
hours per day by about March they were
on for 13 to 15 hours per day and then
by April May they were on for about 10
hours per day the high-pressure sodium
array used a lot more electricity so
about three times more kilowatt hours of
electricity and so then Erica summed up
the total grams of edible mass that was
produced and then we talked about par
efficacy or lighting efficacy then we
can calculate what we call biomass
efficacy so how many grams of edible
mass do you get per kilowatt hour of
electricity and what we find is for each
of the crop cycles we see about two and
a half to three times higher biomass
efficacy for the LED fixtures and then
of course over time the less that we had
to add supplemental light like that
harvest three we also saw higher biomass
efficacy over time all right
and let me show one more small piece of
research and then we'll
stop for questions so this was a project
that my student Jonathan Allred did
during his master's degree and he stayed
on now for his PhD where he's looking at
strawberries in terms of microgreens
these are many different species of
leafy greens that are harvested at the
first true leaf stage and we see them as
kind of garnishes at restaurants kind of
a high-value crop growers tell us that
can sometimes get $30 per pound selling
them to restaurants but there's very
little published scientific information
about how to actually produce these and
so Jonathan looked at things like
temperature and fertility and seeding
density he also looked at light and
carbon dioxide so he wanted to look at
what how much light do we need to
deliver to these crubs to get optimal
yield can cover in dioxide reduce that
need for supplemental light but does it
impact nutrition and so in these
experiments
pora Jonathan so he had these four mini
plexi glass growth chambers and they
were placed in these two larger growth
chambers and he would use the larger
growth chambers to control the light
that the crops received and then within
the the mini chambers he could control
the carbon dioxide concentration so he
had 16 different treatments I'm looking
at Jonathan so for daily light integrals
that ranged from 3 up to 12 moles per
meter squared per day and then within
each of those four different carbon
dioxide concentrations ranging from 400
to 12 or 1,000 parts per million so 16
treatment combinations and then he did
three replicates of each and so what we
see on the x-axis is daily like integral
increasing from 3 to 12 moles per meter
squared per day so with mustard we see
this linear increase and they may
actually prefer more than 12 moles per
meter squared per day with arugula we
see a quadratic response where somewhere
between 10 to 12 moles per meter squared
per day we're
trading their response to light and then
these dashed lines show us their
response to co2 supplementation so we
did see increased yield with higher
carbon dioxide concentration instead of
like in an extreme example if we had at
six moles of light and eight hundred or
a thousand parts per million co2 we
could nearly equal the growth of ambient
co2 at twice the amount of light and
then one would wonder about the
nutritional content of this crop and so
as kind of a proxy for nutrition that
was relatively easy to do with the
colorimetry
calorimeter at our lab Jonathan looked
at total phenolics concentration and so
total phenolics mustards
basically doubled from 40 milligrams of
galactic acid equivalent up to 80
milligrams as light increased from 3 to
12 o so more light gave us higher
phenolic content we also saw that with
arugula although not quite as extreme so
growing from about 75 to about 95
milligrams and then interestingly and I
think optimist a good thing is that
we're finding some of the higher co2
concentrations at least at the high
light level also gave us higher
phenomics concentration all right so
that was kind of a whirlwind of CEA and
lighting I think I'll stop there for
questions yes Ben
za require like special varieties of
fruit vegetables and people reading
those yes there's there's this whole
breeding industry around CEA what I see
it especially is in tomatoes peppers and
cucumbers where they're breeding crops
specifically for greenhouses with
supplemental lighting with lettuce
we're now
being more of that traditionally with
lettuce you would take varieties that
were used in the field and you would
screen them and see if they work for
your operation just similar to the
approach that Erica took um now we're
seeing companies that are actually
breeding lettuce specifically for CEA
and I think it to talk about Jonathan's
work with strawberries so there is some
some work around the world with green
house strawberries and often those are
using day-neutral cultivars
so using everbearing cultivars that can
can produce year round
other questions
Marvin yes who are the folks investing
in this I think these are futurists with
deep pockets some of the there's a
there's a company called on plenty that
got two hundred million dollars in
investment in late 2017 and I don't I
don't really know who their investors
are but it's said to be smart money like
not just risky venture capital the
people that are expecting return on
their investment and so I think some of
our economics work you know looks at
cost but it doesn't look at profit which
I do also question profit but the
thought being it okay it could be more
expensive to produce this way but can it
bring a higher price at market one of
the things we're seeing with urban CEA
is they're kind of cutting out the
middlemen so there's less of a need for
wholesalers and so one of the ways that
they're getting somewhat higher revenue
is by selling directly to to the
supermarket or the restaurant or the
consumer into that yeah none of mine is
going into this industry yeah yes Geneva
do you have any questions thanks Matt
wonderful talk we do not have any
questions right and if we could cool it
we could probably grow broccoli in a
greenhouse
as well we have the technology thank you
let me go here first front of the room a
question about the economics of the
urban growth what do you think are some
upcoming technologies that would have
the best cost impact I know there's a
lot of various things around ionized
water capture also systems that attach
power generation to Jimmy joy but output
and possibly more mechanization with
moving convertible racks what sort of
things do you think would be the biggest
impact for you no comment
yeah so I do think there are there is a
lot of innovation and that will address
these um these on high input cost issues
I don't know if it can completely
address them but if we remember the
table of inputs labor turned out to be a
very high input in both greenhouses and
vertical farms and the assumptions
assumed a not very automated facility
and so we are seeing a lot of attention
being put into robotics and
mechanization and trying to automate
processes I've been in touch with a
robotics company in the Bay Area that's
that's trying to make robots that can
move around our stacks of hydroponic
ponds and then transplant them taking
away some of the more labor expensive
parts I think water strangely seems to
be not a very high cost whether you're
in a field or in a greenhouse or in a
vertical farm but water availability and
climate change may eventually affect
where where things are grown so it's one
thing to be able to pay for water but if
there's not even water there to pay for
you may have to rethink where you're
growing crops let me do the side first
yes about the labor and make it easier
to attract I guess people to you know
like a greenhouse environment you know
you might have a year-round job versus
like
seasonal job fuel yes right in terms of
labor that's definitely one of the
dimensions that we see is is then it's
turning from seasonal labor into to
year-round labor and we do think that is
is making the labor situation more
secure for these CEA operations and Mike
versus right so getting that like the
food safety issues yeah right so the
question is do the do the economics take
into account lost on lettuce from
recalls for example or lawsuits from
from causing illnesses it does not it
would take into account kind of average
reported yields from facilities and
farms often do you have to have
liability insurance which can factor
into the operational cost but that is
one of the one of the things that we're
seeing in terms of the growth of the the
CEA industry is while it doesn't
eliminate food safety issues you still
have to care about worker hygiene and
the water that you're using to grow the
produce and process the produce it does
give you more points of control so you
typically don't have wild animals flying
around your your warehouse or your
greenhouse farm for example so we think
it may be easier to reach food safety
targets in a controlled environment
yes stun meal or a comment and question
I recall another example team member a
number of years ago giving a lecture in
this room how vertical farming would
never be financially feasible yes yes
couraging to see that things change yes
and we we look to Lou Albright's thought
process in many ways and kind of his
playing devil's advocate has factored
into many of the projects that we do
like okay what is the
status now what what is there left to
optimize mm-hmm Jonathan there seems
today certainly in the urban perspective
there seems to be sort of this
hybridization of operations what you
were talking about plank mag release
greenhouse project you know climate
factories have this energy cause
greenhouses have this sort of laying
cause a lot of the operations and some
of the ones that use so took pictures of
seem to be more hybrid between those two
sort of are you seeing more of that and
you know it seems like right I look at
the city exceptionally like God trees
he's really a hybrid time a plant
factory before I know there's the
tractor-trailer
yeah right right uh there is some of a
blending not as much as I might expect
but the kind of concept that actually
Finger Lakes fresh was maybe maybe one
of the first to try is the seed lean
area was indoors under light so when the
crop is dense and uniformity and fast
growth is very important so that that
was indoors and then finishing of the
produce was done in a in a greenhouse
where you can take advantage of sunlight
and you could envision a larger
commercial operation that like like you
say would take the waste heat that would
come out of a vertical farm and use that
to supply heat to a greenhouse
environment yeah I think the high
capital cost we also see a lot more done
with geothermal in the Netherlands and I
think they're there geothermal climate
is actually conducive to it but it is it
is a high capital cost in New York has a
more extreme climate than in the
Netherlands all right I'm at time I'll
stick around and talk to anybody who
wants to talk
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu